[Applause]
these are the seven most powerful men in
China they represent the top leadership
positions of the ruling party and their
identities are revealed every 5 years at
a carefully choreographed political
event called the National Congress
China's Communist Party unveils its new
leadership over the next 5 years the
order of appearance is symbolic the
first person to emerge is the head of
the party for the next 5 years at the
most recent event in October 2022 that
person Xin ping China's president for
the last 10 years who walked out in the
top spot a historic third time after
getting rid of China's presidential term
limit that restricted all his
predecessors to two terms a signal that
he may be planning to stay in power for
Life the world hasn't seen a Chinese
leader like this since Ma satum the
Revolutionary founder of the People's
Republic of China whose ruthless
dictatorship scarred the Chinese people
for Generations she has been compared to
Mao a lot and he clearly draws from
Mao's Playbook but there's something
else that connects these two when she
was just a young boy Mao ruined his life
Generations apart their paths crossed
unexpectedly and a teenage shei from an
elite family in Beijing ended up in
Exile condemned to hard labor in the
countryside 50 years later she is one of
the most powerful political figures in
the world and the only leader since Ma
to have unchecked power over China so
how did he go from being banished in his
country to taking complete control of
[Music]
it xiin Ping's connection to Mao formed
long before she was even
born it goes back to when a bloody Civil
War was raging in
China a group of radical communist
revolutionaries including Mao gained
influence over large swats of mainland
China and controlled a communist
military called the Red Army that fought
the Nationalist party ruling the
Republic of China at the time at this
point the Communists were losing bad the
bulk of their army was pinned down here
in a communist controlled region
originally established by Mao now
surrounded by nationalist forces and
they were running low on food so the Red
Army decided to launch a bold attack to
break through the nationalist forces and
Evacuate the roughly 130,000 communist
soldiers and civilians stuck here on
October 16th 1934 they made their move
and attacked a weaker part of the enemy
line they broke through and even though
their numbers quickly dropped with
thousands dying and thousands more
fleeing to the countryside around 86,000
stuck together and pushed on this was
the beginning of a year-long historic
retreat called the Long March the
journey to establish a new communist
base far from the nationalist
forces
Mao who used to be a military leader
wasn't in charge at this time he'
insisted on using Guerilla tactics which
had heavily influenced the Red Army
earlier in the war but that approach had
fallen out of favor and he was demoted
the Long March changed that after
Escaping The Siege here the Red Army
continued to suffer Relentless attacks
by the pursuing nationalist Army the
military leaders of the March had pushed
for a more traditional wartime strategy
of direct confrontation rather than Ma's
Guerilla tactics and the result was
catastrophic for the Red Army less than
half of the original Escape group
survived the first 3 months alone so it
was at this first stopping point where
Communist party leader Jo and lie handed
military leadership back to Mao and Mao
picked an end point for the march here
800 M away in rural northern China but
they didn't go straight for it Ma led
the Red Army deep into the mountains
where he predicted lighter resistance
and he was right but the journey was was
still brutal it was nine more months of
non-stop marching and fighting along
this several thousand mile route before
they ultimately arrived in northern
China where a gorilla base led by a
communist revolutionary named XI Jong
shun offered ma Army Refuge bringing the
Long March to an
end that man was xiin Pink's
father in the end fewer than 8,000 of
the original Marchers
survived even though thousands died on
the Long March from starvation fighting
and disease mau's leadership was
credited with saving the Red Army from
Total Annihilation and he became the
deao head of the party as well as the
military entrusted with rebuilding the
Army to take on the nationalist forces
for total control of China wherever and
however the red troops move into battle
they spread the glory of
Mount this is a good stopping point in
the story to talk about how power in the
Chinese Communist party or CCP Works
officially the highest level of
authority is a group called The Central
Committee and is responsible for all of
the party's major policy decisions
within the central committee is a select
group of officials called the political
Bureau or polit Bureau in most communist
parties like that of the former Soviet
Union the poot Bureau represents the
most powerful members of the party
besides the general secretary but the
Chinese Communist party has a key
distinction that makes it unique it has
one more even smaller selection of top
officials who ultimately had the final
say an Elite Class of pal buau members
called the pal buau standing committee
this group which includes the general
secretary holds supreme control over the
Central Committee dictates the will of
the party and is in full control of the
central military commission which
oversees China's
defense Ma's promotion during the Long
March landed him here in the highest
position of the military and palpo
standing committee even though he was
considered the the deao head of the
party when the Long March ended in 1935
he officially became head of the party
in
1943 with both the party and the
military under his control ma began to
exploit the system to ensure he remained
at the top for the rest of his
life at Ma's First National Congress as
the official party leader in
1945 the party introduced a resolution
that brought his influence to a whole
new
level it unified the party around a
single understanding of its history and
declared Mao's political ideology later
called Maat Tonk thought or maoism as
the unquestioned guiding principle of
the Chinese Communist Party basically
Ma's ideas or policy decisions could no
longer be challenged by
anyone it was here he unveiled his
equivalent at the time of the pilot
Bureau standing committee the four other
top Party leaders all long Marchers
deeply loyal to ma like Lu shiai and
Joan li who would go on to hold some of
the most powerful positions in the
future government four years later ma
declared final victory for the
Communists in the decades long Chinese
Civil War and established a new country
the People's Republic of China or PRC
Mong once a lonly party worker now
assumed the stature of the dominant
figure in all of Eastern
Asia but winning a revolution isn't the
same as running a country because now
that you're running a country there's
all these other things you have to do
like deliver the mail and like build a
dam and and stuff like that you can't
possibly have the party do all these
things so the party set up a government
that would take the policy decisions
made by the poipo standing committee and
figure out a way to make them a reality
and so it evolved to a system where the
party would make all the important
decisions and especially the hall
bureau's standing committee then as it
is today many of these decisions would
go to the state Council so the state
council is the highest decision-making
body on the state side led by the
premier of China the premier of China by
the way is almost always a member of the
P buau standing committee One Way Mau
kept a tight grip on power over the
years was by promoting those loyal to
him to top positions in the party and
government whether they had government
experience or not for example Z and Li
the former party leader who helped ma
rise to power during the Long March
became China's first
premier the advantage of that is that
they could never challenge him the
disadvantage of that is they didn't know
what they were doing and so
Administration suffered policy outcome
suffered long march survivors often
became party Elites under Mao xen Pink's
father for example was appointed
Secretary General of the state Council
and as the son of a long marcher y shei
was given the informal title of prining
ma succeeded in never giving up his
power during his lifetime his unchecked
policies resulted in massive famines and
widespread persecution that cost between
40 and 80 million lives over a span of
decades and culminated in the disastrous
cultural revolution a violent final
attempt from Mao to consolidate his
power and force loyalty to the practice
of
maoism the idea was to make himself and
his ideas Eternal the way he viewed
communist figureheads like Lenin and
marks before him anyone that didn't fall
in line with Ma's ideology was publicly
humiliated in impoverished excluded from
society and in many cases
executed either at the hands of the army
or by a militant youth group obsessed
with enforcing maoism the red
[Music]
guards even those closest to the
dictator weren't safe from his purges
during the cultural revolution high
level officials including members MERS
of the paler standing committee and long
Marchers were removed from their
positions Loui was denounced as a
traitor and died while imprisoned under
harsh conditions Mao also removed the
chief of staff of the army and replaced
him with a maist leaving no one left to
oppose him in the military M hampi's
successor who always appeared loyally by
his side in photos and propaganda
posters died under mysterious
circumstances when his plane crashed as
he was fleeing to the Soviet Union ma
later denounced him as a traitor
he denounced she's father too this is a
photo of shei senior being restrained
and publicly criticized by the red
guards at the height of the cultural
revolution he would remain a prisoner in
Beijing for8 years following
this with his father purged xiin ping 15
at the time was expelled from his Elite
School in Beijing and sent to work in
the countryside he had to live in a cave
and you know do heart manual labor his
food was barely enough for you know a
growing young person and chairman ma was
responsible for all of
it but then ma died the cultural
revolution ended his successor was dcha
ping one of the poier standing committee
members who was removed from power
during the culture Revolution who just
before ma died started making a promise
to fellow exiled party
veterans dcha ping signal credibly to
all the surviving long Marchers that he
wanted to rehabilitate people so when
Mao died they all supported the
rehabilitation of dung and as soon as
dung was rehabilitated he went ahead and
rehabilitated all these people with
experienced leadership back in place the
party needed to figure out how to
prevent something like
[Music]
this from ever happening again in order
to undo Mouse Cult of Personality the
party introduced a second historical
resolution in 1981 it condemned periods
of Ma's Rule and emphasize A Renewed
commitment to Collective leadership
vowing to oppose the consolidation of
power around one person moving forward
the successors to ma didn't want a a
dictatorship so they divided up these
positions and put them in the hands of
different people like Mao dun kept tight
control over the central military
commission as its chairman and held a
leadership position in the government
but was never head of state he never
held the highest position in the party
either instead he set up a new advisory
commission and served as its chairman
which allowed him to influence the
party's Direction without positioning
himself directly on top of it this
allowed a power sharing structure while
still making dung the deao leader of
China until he stepped down in 1989
following the Army's Massacre of
students protesting in tianan square a
protester suddenly ran into the middle
of the street and in front of the
oncoming tanks anger at dung shaing the
entire Chinese government it had the
real feeling of rebellion in the streets
of Beijing people want to fight the
military out of their
City dung in his ideology which moved
away from malism set a precedent of
sharing power he opened up China and
established economic ties with these
countries and was the first PRC leader
to visit the US in 1979 today we take
another step in the historic
normalization of relations which we have
begun this year
dung's reforms became the foundation for
decades of economic Prosperity that led
China to having the world's second
largest economy over time and being on
the verge of becoming the world's next
superpower communism is creating a
consumer Society also reminds you that
the standard of living in China is going
up here capitalism
rules one thing power sharing did lead
to was a lot of policy Innovation and
then some degree of decentral ization
and both of these things helped China's
economy enormously which is why this
period of economic growth and reform
stretching over roughly 30 years is
known as the dung era and whether he
wanted to or not dung kept his word and
never tried to consolidate absolute
power around himself he did end up
sharing power and that set the stage for
power sharing in the party until the
rise of Xi Jinping so what was she all
this
time when Ma died in 1976 she was back
in Beijing studying communist
philosophy even though the Chinese
Communist Party had ruined she's family
he had joined it just as the cultural
revolution was winding down but why
personally he might begrudge chman ma
for doing all these terrible things to
his family but I think at this time he
also recognized that in the system of
the Chinese Communist Party pow is
everything
without power you're nothing but in
order to get that power she did
something unexpected he left Beijing as
his competitors were fiercely competing
with each other in 1980s and 1990s he
sort of got out of their way and went to
the
provinces he took positions in party
leadership in rural poor provinces all
around China where there were no other
princelings to compete with first in Hub
a poor rural Province outside of Beijing
where he easily reached the top spot as
party secretary then in fujan a heavily
militarized region where Top members of
the army were stationed he moved at the
ranks to party secretary here too before
becoming the governor of the province a
few years later after making powerful
friends in the military she went here
where he once again assumed the office
of party secretary and grew his support
on the civilian
side this strategy of moving around
didn't just give XI a leg up in areas
where competition was slim it also gave
him credibility
as a humble hardworking party leader and
he cultivated a growing group of
supporters who would come back into play
years down the
line it was his last stop and his
shortest one that ultimately got him
back to
Beijing a brief stin in the top party
spot in Shanghai in 2007 where he
rehabilitated the city's image following
a highlevel corruption Scandal she
developed a reputation here as a prudent
leader who towed the party line just 7
months later he finally returned to
Beijing having been promoted to the all
powerful pipiro standing committee
basically the people who were deciding
on top leadership at the time they
wanted a princeling but they didn't want
a princeling who was too ambitious or
too strong so xiin ping he was seen as
less ambitious because he was willing to
go to the countryside and and work in
lower level
positions when she emerged at the 2007
National Congress and Leadership
unveiling he was one of the nine most
powerful men in the country it was at
this moment that his strategic climb
over 17 long years in the countryside
paid off big
time when the general secretary stepped
down in 2012 she emerged at the top spot
in the party as China's leader now the
elite son of a former revolutionary
turned exiled peasant turned party
darling was poised to seize control of
[Music]
everything like Mao xiin ping believes
that rallying around a single figure is
crucial to the party survival rather
than the collective leadership dung's
reforms had normalized so pretty much as
soon as Xin ping came to power he
started getting rid of
people the new four top officials
removed for taking bribes was announced
on state TV Shin ping has just sacked
his foreign minister just sacked his
defense minister he sacked a whole lot
of other people at the top of the
military establishment the former
security Zar has not been seen in public
for more than a year the investigation
against hu allows the Chinese president
to remove those opposed to his reforms
he launched a major anti-corruption
campaign as soon as he took power in
late 2012 early 13 which led to the
arrests of hundreds of senior level
officials as well as Military Officers
these purges targeted she's rivals in
the party whose vacant positions he
filled with his own supporters after
this massive Purge XI Jin Pang was in
very tight control over both the party
and also the Chinese military thereby
making him the most powerful leader of
the Chinese Communist Party since the
death of ma that pattern continued in
the second term where he unveiled five
new faces of the palip standing
committee three of them with close
personal ties to shei in 2021 shei
pulled off one of his most dramatic acts
yet to enforce his influence over the
Chinese Communist
Party he introduced a third historic
resolution that unified the party's
ideology around one clear line of
thinking XI jimp ping thought she's
personal political ideology would now be
the core in the party's thinking
political stance and action basically XI
jinping's ideas could no longer be
challenged and they weren't for many
years during she first 10 years in power
the size of China's economy more than
doubled so did average individual income
so did military spending under his
leadership China's presence on the world
stage has grown too positioning the
rising superpower to take on the role of
an aggressor externally reasserting
claims over parts of the South China Sea
intimidating Taiwan and Tibet and
stripping Democratic process in Hong
Kong inside its own borders strict
internet censorship and surveillance are
widespread and oppression of Wagers a
mostly minority Muslim ethnic group is
marked by human rights
abuses but it wasn't until Co that she
saw the first real challenge to his
authority anger in China is growing
video showing protesters in Shin Jang
fed up with China's zero covid
rules the boldest public challenge yet
for leader xiin ping with these protests
all around the country and the party's
reputation in Peril she reversed the
failed policy
but is now faced with a shaky economy
and cracks in his unchecked
authority it was just weeks before the
widespread protests at the 20th National
Congress in
2022 that she walked out in the leading
position a third time he had already
locked in the presidency for another 5
years and unveiled a poo standing
committee completely packed with those
loyal to him after removing the final
scene senior members of the party that
had ties to his
predecessor now there is no one left in
party or military leadership whose
ideology differs from she I don't think
anyone can push him out at this point I
think he will be the most powerful
leader in
China as long as he's alive and
conscious thanks so much for watching
this episode of Atlas so many teammates
worked on this piece a small army of
editors animators and researchers helped
bring this complicated story into Focus
I'd especially like to shout out Raja
one of the key researchers on this piece
who conducted an incredible interview
with our expert Victor shei it takes a
lot of resources to make these videos
but we publish our work free to watch
here because we think journalism should
be accessible to everyone if you believe
in keeping journalism free and want to
support our continuing work go to
vox.com now to make a contribution
thanks
again